One of the best parts of being a
developer advocate is the opportunity to
talk to developers and designers around
the world in building amazing things.
And we talk about their existing
integrations, ways to make them more
performant, how to take advantage
of new services and increasingly,
how to extend them to new form
factors and more parts of users lives.
And in these conversations,
I hear a lot of great ideas.
Some of these ideas can be
characterized like this.
Incredibly cool [LAUGH] while
also not useful at all.
And herein lies a central issue
with building for new form factors.
Often our imaginations run so
far to the science fiction of our art,
that we forget to make sure we're
solving actual user problems and
then test to make sure our
solution is a good one.
That's why we're going to
take a few moments right now
to discuss the big picture of design for
new form factors as a baseline for
our more detailed design
discussions later in the course.